let's have a chat about college football
the DirecTV 4k college football report
once again care of DirecTV 4k as well as
our front Bruce Feldman here on the show
of Fox Sports and si.com good to see you
back here let's get it right into it
Bruce what scoop what's going on with
Chip Kelly best you can tell me right
now right now he is much in demand kind
of as we expected on Sunday University
of Florida brass there was six six
members of their leadership including
the president of school as well as the
ad went to visit him in in New Hampshire
I was told the meeting both sides felt
like the meeting went well so UCLA
visited him and no that's Florida now
UCLA I'm told the meeting and I was
reported someplace else that it was in
Los Angeles I'm told that actually
wasn't in Los Angeles but he met with
UCLA people they're making their pitch
and we'll see how it goes he talked to a
lot of people who either work with Chip
Kelly or know him really well they all
think he is a better fit or fits more
out here in Los Angeles UCLA obviously
as you alluded to earlier to pay 12
million-plus to get rid of Jim Mora you
don't do that to go hire Brian Harsin
from Boise State you do that to go get
Chip Kelly and so the questions gonna be
are how committed are they to football
and to the level of USC is way more
committed to football and certainly a
lot of these SEC SEC schools are then
UCLA and what I mean by that is not
necessarily I really don't think that
Chip Kelly is gonna is gonna not choose
you see later choose it whether they pay
him an extra three hundred thousand
dollars what I think is the important
part to him is the relationships he has
with the people above him but also are
they going to do things in sports
performance and the athlete developments
pieces pays like a assistants yeah but
also just the support part that goes
into football and some of the programs
around it and I think that's an that's
an important thing because he was really
a pioneer in that for all the talk about
his offense in his run game right you
know when we do games each week you go
around you talk to college coaches a lot
of them have changed our practice
schedule what they do on Thursday as
opposed to Fridays because of what Chip
Kelly used to do I mean he's made that
big of an
imprint on how college programs are
running it's beyond just the exit note
now I would think UCLA would have had
their seriousness indicated about
football by by cutting a 12 million
dollar check just to be in this
sweepstakes with Chip Kelly that might
be number one and if you're gonna spend
that money then then you got to throw
more good money after after that at
least that would that that's to me I'm
also hearing by the way that that Chip
Kelly signing in college gets the Niners
off the hook that they don't have to pay
him so he's not as cheap as you think oh
that would be do that is what I am here
and I hadn't heard that part of it yeah
don't know that I I'm hearing that there
are some people in San Francisco that
are have their popcorn ready and
champagnes to pop the minute he signs on
a dotted line well that's the case you
know that they're gonna be really cuz
he's gonna end up somewhere he's not
gonna stay in TV you know I think
looking at this also from just a dynamic
standpoint he's not a guy who wants to
be in the middle of a fishbowl and
that's what you would have had at
Tennessee to some degree I think you
have that at Florida although not as
much as some other SEC schools out here
on the west coast you know there's so
many other things people just I think
are more conditioned you know when
you're the head coach of an SEC program
you're like the most important person in
the state you know if you're the head
coach at UCLA you know you're not having
the most important guy on the campus
yeah I mean I don't know if that's levar
ball clearly obviously you know he's in
the news all the time but it's not even
like you know people whether you're clay
Helton or whoever yeah you know it's a
football coach and I think it's also you
know you go you get to go about your
business and do what you want and I
don't think there's as many that
entanglements that you have at some
other programs and I think that probably
is appealing there bruce Feldman here in
the DirecTV 4k college football report
so who would Florida be looking at if
not Kelly and and vice versa you know my
gut would say that they would turn to
his protege Scott frost who's at UCF has
done a terrific job there when Scott
frost got there two years ago they were
a winless team and they were at the
bottom of the country in offense now
they are 10 and OH
there have the most explosive offenses
the country and that's less than two
years so he's done a fantastic job he's
got a lot of developed a lot of
recruiting ties he can he can also get
there and the question is Scott frost
went to Nebraska you know that job is
likely to come open you know I could see
his heart being there but it is his head
gonna be there to want to go because you
can get a lot better players in
Gainesville Florida or in Tallahassee if
that job comes open in Florida State
then you certainly can at Nebraska
DIRECTV for K college football report
here with Bruce Feldman what's going on
at Texas A&M
what's happening there well they're
ready to pull the plug on Kevin someone
the the new ad there Scott Woodward he
pretty much put him on notice he went on
you know the SEC network at the SEC
meetings and basically said if he
doesn't have a better year you know it's
it's over and they've had a decent year
and not good enough you know they lost
three games to top 15 opponents they
lost the game against UCLA early on yeah
I read the Regents Facebook rant yeah I
mean there's been stuff out of the
woodwork it's been all over the place
and so yesterday the Houston Chronicle
had reported that they are prepared they
are going to fire Kevin someone after
the season finale which is Saturday
night at LSU and they're gonna fire him
whether he wins or loses and from
talking to guys on that stab I talked to
one of the assistant coaches last night
I said how did you find out about the
report he said was basically when I was
coming off the practice field I saw I
had six messages and two were firm
recruits he said it's really and he used
some colorful language a bad deal for
the players to find out that you know no
matter what it doesn't matter what you
do on Saturday night and he goes all
these guys were recruited by Kevin
someone it's not sitting well especially
in light of what did you know the the ad
kind of putting them on blast before the
season even started so what who who's on
a short list they're you know much like
what you were talking about with with
Jim Mora and UCLA you know Scott wood
where the ad used to be at LSU he's a
deputy ad there and he had worked with
Jimbo Fisher who was under Nick Saban I
think that that is the swing for the
fences guy that they're gonna try to get
Jimbo Fisher who's won a national title
but having an awful season this year in
Tallahassee and has ruffled some
feathers you know in the wake of this
you know four and six season because
he's complained about facilities people
there want you don't want him to make
some staff shake-up if he was gonna
leave and there's been other times where
people you know
axis LSU other schools have had interest
in him and he has wanted he is
you know stayed there if there was a
time to leave this punt might be the
time and a.m. could pay him a lot of
money to go back to the SEC so we'll see
what he does if he doesn't take it I
don't know what they do because Kevin
someone one bigger than anybody's one
there is a first time in 50-plus years
they were in the top about a top-five
finish yes so what do you do if he if
you don't get Jimbo Fisher to go after
Gary Kubiak I don't know what they would
do um now I'm gonna I'm gonna tread on
the ground that that that people love to
rip me for and rag on me for okay all
the NFL talent evaluators just love
texting me hey I'm here and they're
coming for your guy in Ann Arbor I hear
they're coming I hear that the Browns
and the Colts and the Bears are gonna
back up the truck are you hearing
anything about that with Harbaugh and
Michigan right now Bruce I'd be
surprised if he were to leave now think
about this and take your uh you know
yourself out of this and your heart out
if I have if you get so because this is
a this is a topic of the Scott and again
I don't know if these talent evaluators
are doing it just to rip me and just
poke at me I can to have it could be
that to you you have a guy who is ultra
competitive we know that he got this job
he has not beaten his archrival to this
point you know that obviously they play
Ohio State this weekend yes sir he has
struggled with Michigan State he's
struggled on you know in the big games
that you know if you're the Michigan
coach you really need to win his team is
a year away probably because he had the
fewest returning starters coming into
this season he's got a young quarterback
we'll see what happens whether it's
Brandon Peters whether it's Christian
McCaffrey his little brother Dylan Dylan
McCaffrey whatever that whatever's gonna
be that all that defense a lot of those
guys are gonna be back they should be
really good next year do you really
think he's gonna go yeah I got this as
my you know my family loves it here the
situation where you know the
grandparents around the kids everything
now it's not to say he couldn't get a
similar dynamic cuz he's got so much
money that you could probably create
that kind of ecosystem I just find it
hard to believe that he would pull the
plug after all it took to get this
situation at Michigan and to do the
heavy lifting to do some of this stuff
that he would go bolt back to the NFL he
could do that a year from now he could
do that two years from now so why would
he do it
when you've you left unfinished business
on the table because he may not get this
opportunity to be the Michigan coach if
Michigan feels that that it's special to
him you know it's different from an NFL
team or an NFL organization he's gonna
get those opportunities down the road
well in a few minutes I have left in
this DirecTV 4k college football report
Alabama Auburn who do you think wins
that one who wins the Iron Bowl my hunch
is that that Alabama will I just think
too many people have pounded onto this
this born bandwagon and I think Alabama
their matchup I think Jalen Hurd's has
played in a lot of big games even though
he's only a sophomore already I think he
matches up well with what they do
compared to some of the stuff the Auburn
defense as talented as they are like to
now one caveat here is if Albarn running
back carry on Johnson runs like he did
against Georgia and that's a really good
defense and he does it on you know in
the Iron Bowl I don't think he can
overtake Baker Baker may feel but he's
gonna leapfrog all these other talented
running backs into the Heisman race okay
and then where's an upset this weekend
possible South Carolina could they shock
me good you know they're eight and three
they have a young quarterback Jake
Bentley who's talented the one reason
why I would say keep an eye on that one
is because there's been so much talk
about Clemson going up in the s in the
ACC title game against an undefeated
Miami and turnover chain and how Miami's
defenses play it and all this where I
think it's gonna be you know I know it's
a rivalry game they're not gonna they're
not gonna take South Carolina lightly
Will Muschamp quietly he's done a really
good job in Columbia South Carolina and
Baker Mayfield we had Marcus Mariota on
and he said that he's honestly on the
fence about what Baker Mayfield did on
the sidelines against Kansas yeah I know
they're probably some voters who are
probably gonna be the same way I just
think the gap between Baker Mayfield and
everybody else you can't have him if you
you know I'm not saying this is Marcus
but you can't have him number two on
your ballot if you're you know thinking
that way he's either not on the ballot
or you have him number one to me he's
clearly the most outstanding player did
he do something really stupid and
immature yes but I think there's plenty
of an you know Marcus turned out he was
you know using just a great kid we don't
know that all those
guys who were voting for necessarily our
you know we just know it will work you
know working with it in the grand scheme
of things what he did was it immature
yes was it something you know there's a
lot of awful stuff that we find out
about in this day and age to me it
wasn't let's I want to put it in
perspective I don't think it was
anywhere near on that level where I
would say I'm taking them off my ballot
and you're doing the Apple Cup this
weekend we are we we go up to Seattle
first thing Friday morning can't wait to
see it it's gonna be a you know Chris
Peterson Washington have a chance to
play spoiler and knock wazoo their
archrival out of the pac-12 title and
Stanford sitting right there right yeah
I mean they're waiting in it waiting
where the bryce love is had a terrific
season but you know washington state has
a chance to do something I haven't done
in a long time and is there anybody on
the staff covering the game that needs
marital advice from I wholly not because
he you don't you don't want to hear from
Mike and let it go on a rant I mean that
was fantastic we're gonna play that in
its full glory in the third hour just
before Bob Saget works in here that's
gonna be a lot of fun have a great time
up at the Apple Cup and we'll chat with
you hopefully you have a great
Thanksgiving is a great Thanksgiving you
too and we'll chat before everything
really goes haywire it's already going I
love it man that's Bruce Feldman at
Bruce Feldman cfb it's the most follow
on Twitter check him out on Fox Saturday
at 8:00 Eastern Time the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience